thousands have been killed after a
massive earthquake in turkey and Syria
now a huge rescue operation is underway
and every minute is crucial
the first thing Rescuers need to do is
coordinate both with people in the
country and International Help coming
from around the world what's becoming
clear is that this is huge so it's a
it's an international effort that will
need very very careful coordination and
it's unclear whether they'll be able to
get that at the moment
next is about analysis on the ground
specialist rescue workers need to figure
out exactly where they're most likely to
find survivors
strong buildings are often the first
place they'll look searching for what
they call voids that can be spaces like
stairwells or under collapsed beams
where people could be seeking shelter
local knowledge is critical here with
people from the area likely to know the
best and safest places to start
searching
then it comes to the actual response
workers have to stabilize the area
making sure it's safe to extract people
then you see diggers being brought in to
try and move the debris
heavy lifting equipment chainsaws disc
Cutters whatever that can help to move
as much debris and Rubble as quickly as
possible
this is just now a race to get to
survivors and that's a rich it's just an
impossible stage
these first hours are vital the longer
it takes to treat serious injuries and
get people food and water the less
likely workers are to find survivors
rescue operations like this tend to last
between five and seven days then The
Rescuers need to make the difficult
decision to stop looking for new
survivors and work on helping the ones
already pulled from the rubble